when you're sitting there and they take
shots at you you get affected by it
right yeah you saw my set I get up and I
talk about Blake Griffin who's there
Blake Griffin good-looking guy
basketball player dated kendall Jenner
just like a hot yeah and most of the
jokes were about the fact that he's a
black guy but has white features yeah I
said he looked like a black guy that got
made by a printer running out of ink so
he just looks at look yes his red hair
it mean he's but in person he's so hot I
see someone you'd be interested in
dating yeah yeah I like a hot guy that's
out of my league so yes do you go to
these rows hoping that maybe I'll hook
up with somebody not hook up but I don't
hook up anymore what I'm looking for you
know really yeah yeah so when I knew he
was gonna be there I was like I'm just
gonna write all my jokes about how much
I want to have sex with him just to let
him know it's an easy way to just get
that right there smart it really that's
how we communicate with men so what did
you say like oh you're so hot I'd want
to [ __ ] you yeah I was just like I I
think I was talking about Sean Hayes
being on Will and Grace and how his
catchphrase was just jack to check and I
said it's also what I'm gonna be doing
in my hotel room tonight after sitting
next to Blake Griffin all evening
was he expressing any interest in you
did you see after your set did he say
hey you know I don't know if you're
kidding around but that doesn't have to
be a fantasy yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] your
brain well no okay so I do a bunch of
jokes I'm like I would I just want to
I'd [ __ ] you in front of my grandparents
is what I told him and it's like I
almost want to just to show off and and
I'm successful you exactly I made it I
just really went hard it was 22 because
when I was writing all these jokes
people are like um this is supposed to
be a roast you're not supposed to like
bladders like but this is how I'm gonna
get this is how I'm gonna tell him and I
knew he wouldn't have jokes about
wanting to have sex with me but I didn't
know he was gonna get up you know five
minutes later and all of his jokes are
about how he would never [ __ ] me
have you ever declared your love to
someone and then have them say you look
like Larry Bird I knew it would happen
but I didn't know it really was
insulting and and hurt my feelings did
you talk to him after as he called you
is he interested I mean you threw
yourself at him he sits back down after
getting calling me ugly and and I'm like
I just the next this guy for three hours
now like just this is awkward
I just declared my love he's like
wouldn't touch you and by the way after
the roast I like went up to one of my
friends that was a writer on the show
and I was like that was devastating the
jokes that Blake did about me I was like
I'm really like her and she was like oh
they weren't bad my friend Bonnie
McFarlane great writers she was like
they weren't that bad she goes the one
about you looking like the hairdresser
of a girl he might [ __ ] that was great I
go he didn't do that one Bonnie glad
it's on his mind